[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
maybe now we can speak a little in
Spanish Yes, of course, this topic is
great, you have to have pleasure, you don't have
to enjoy learning the language
Because if we focus, we don't concentrate
on the  grammar the basic rules of the
language as an obligation
because there are exams it is not very
difficult to
progress in the language what do you think
I feel that it is more than difficult
it is frustrating for many people like
because a language really And that is
what I always tell people
learning a language is not difficult it is
complex I mean and I mean complex
in terms of it is not like Ah I am going to
English classes for six months and I am going to
learn it does not involve much the
teacher's methodology the material he
is using as well  You say Steve How
much do you like it because it's very easy to give up
something you don't like after a month and
I make that same analogy with the gym a lot a lot
for me learning a
language AND doing exercises Almost almost the
same thing involves having a lot of
willpower  to do it continuously day
by day because what works best is
to do it in my opinion is to do it
self-taught at the same pace with
the things you enjoy And that's the
bad thing about school, not that the content
you consume there is that school
consider better
the I don't know for example the audios you
listen to or the ones that are made are the ones
that the school considers best and many
times it is not optimal for your
learning in particular but because
this is how I understand it does not have to
be general so that it works for the
general population and that is why
I think that is the great weakness of
the instruction in schools of having
a teacher, let's say, who takes you by the
hand, it may be that you are not
interested in what  you are learning and
as you say that is the most
important thing to learn a language that
you have the interest that you enjoy it as
you said yes yes according to Steven's theory
there is an order in the learning of
structures or words or aspects of the
language that there is  a natural order and it doesn't
matter that the teacher is going to teach
this I don't know the subjunctive
and other things the tense in English But
you are going to learn those things according to this
order So you don't have to worry and that's
why the exams the texts make you
Worry above all about the
results of the exam and not letting or
allowing the language to enter your head
no, so you have to stop it, you
have to believe in this natural
learning process and I believe that the way
languages ​​are taught in schools
destroys this  sense of Independence
everything is according to what the teacher says you
are going to study this this content is going for you
I am going to give you a I have taught that thing
Now you are going to let's see you
have learned what I have sealed but
finally the head does not work like
this  way So the
way they teach in
schools is against nature and above all that the
learner does not have this independence
that is so important in
language learning yes And I think that many people
When they hear for example that I
tell them I learned German by watching  Netflix
and really and Well I practiced a little bit
of shadowing later but that was
later. I mean, what I learned the most was
playing video games and watching Netflix,
many people take it as in Mexico,
especially because it is my
non-personal experience here, many people
say no  I mean, you're lying to me, you
're trying to tell me this, I don't know, there's
a very big resignation towards the idea of
learning naturally, as you say, no,
and But and I think
why this still happens today
despite the fact that we have so much content  already
available online that this
really doesn't work for 90% of
people to say a number right because
I feel that some people who are more
logical if it works for them not like they
say Ah a b c d perfect and maybe they'll do it
putting them but  they are The minority
I feel that you have to be a person who
is a genius to learn that way
In my opinion that is what I think I
feel that most of us
learn naturally just by
getting involved and what I tell the
students Get in  to the language wherever it is, it doesn't
matter, there is no way, I mean, there is no
initial step because I know
basic English. I start with the basics and
go with the advanced, it seems strange to me, no,
and I think that that I insist comes from  the idea
of ​​how textbooks are structured
is like by Ah present
simple then present simple
present continuous then present
continuous past simple and so not
then creates this illusion that the
present perfect is a is an
advanced topic and the  Simple present is a
basic subject when that is not true it is
just different instances of
how the language is used But I think that is
why I think it is easier for a
teacher to prepare a class and Establish
a curriculum
a school curriculum I mean
if he does  for skills as well as
chunks not like little squares of the language
that giving a class of comprehensible input
or a class of habits is very
subjective that I don't feel that it is
complicated in fact I would like to
know Steve what do you think about how
this could be done  from the input
as in a classroom
Well This is very difficult but we must
admit that the world has changed and
now there is as much content on the
internet as Netflix as you say and other
things that we don't We don't need the
teacher to give us  all the content
we have to learn from this
non-content there is
everywhere and we can
choose we can look for things of interest and
maybe in a class because
students can study different things
no student a students B student c will
study through  different things and
then they can discuss the content
that they have studied But it is also
a question in this book that in the
video I have talked about this video
anatomical habits that this friends you have to
believe create by yourself
habits activities The important thing is that
Every day, almost every day,
you are as it says. You have
learning activities that you like here, the one you
are in. You have habits to do
things, listen or read or speak every day,
every day, and this is more
important than every test, and that's why.
For example, in the link we
measure
not the level, which is difficult to judge, but
the level of activity and if someone has
good habits that every day is
How to say
with the language, well, they will progress and without
referring to any
text, any exam this
and this good link is more based on
reading it is not this is because every
good thing I start with listening and
listening there I
don't know 20 and 30% since it is hill
that I don't understand and then I will
read and save
sentences and  words to study those
words and phrases there are a lot of
functions that help me learn the
words and phrases through but
always I
start
with listening it happens I spend more time
listening than reading but all this
is part of the input overall I
think  here many many people
have told me hey but how do you start that is
how it starts let's say be honest
not in a language how is it that you can
start learning that language if because
you say for example I understand 20 I don't
understand 20 or 30  % of the words no
but if you're starting from scratch I do
n't think you would understand any no or one or two
Maybe you heard How
Steve coffeman starts learning a language from
scratch because I don't think you start out
understanding 20 or 30% that's cheating
So you already know the language No no how how
that works I start I
start I start with the mini stories
listening he won't understand anything but it
gives me a sense no and then I'm going to read
one sentence at a time and Search for words
and read again Listen again  time and
finally I'm going to listen to the mini
story of 3 minutes and I don't understand
much and come back again Finally and
then it's already bored I'm going to study
the next mini story and I'm not going to
understand much but finally I'm going to
listen like 20 times and listening 20
times and reading five times and saving
phrases and words little by little what was
noise makes sense that is a process
that I have done many times and it works there is
so much repetition in the mini
stories that this one can This works
many many books for beginners
beginners  they don't have
enough repetition when
we start we have to find
those words many many times in the
same story
the same words the same vocabulary
seems like four or five times in a
story and so little by little after
three months I can go looking for more
interesting things  from YouTube or whatever
as
real content
Yes but but come on we can continue and
enjoy for hours and hours and we will
continue on your channel exactly
then I
invite you to my channel to see the
next part
I will leave a link in the
description box  so that everyone
can continue on the Mister Salas Channel,
perfect, thank you very much